[Music]
lisa is in
phoenix hi lisa welcome to the ramsay
show
hi dave thank you
what's up
so i purchased a home in march of 2021
for 675 thousand
i did a remodel of about 200 000
and of that
i had a partner my ex-husband he donated
157 000
in the remodel and the intention was
that we would sell it in march of 2023
make a profit
do that a couple more times and then be
mortgage free
so so the issue is this month my
assessment has decided instead of
waiting until march he wants his money
in august
so i have to come up with 157 000
and so my question is
should i
take a home equity line of credit
out of my current home
or
should i sell one of my investment
properties which i really don't want to
do
because i have equity in both of those
homes the home in question are you
living in it i am okay
but your game plan your game plan was to
sell it next spring
yes
okay but the market has been similar
ex-husband was your husband at the time
that this all went together right no
no no he was my ex we were just business
partners
okay
that's awkward and weird um
all right um
so
i'm guessing then based on the way this
conversation's going that you two
um
did not do a partnership agreement
correct because he could not qualify you
did this on a handshake you have no
written agreement
correct
so he has no more right to decide he
wants the money now
than you do to deny it to him legally
so tell him to pound sand yes
well he has hired an attorney so good to
go to court and spend a lot of money on
attorneys good that's what he's going to
have to do he's going to use up some of
his money on attorneys i guess
this is what happens when you're
partners with your assessment oh my gosh
why is this not predictable um
so uh
what's the downside of selling it now
not to make him happy because there's
nothing in this conversation making me
want to make him happy
and both of you ought to have your butts
kicked for not doing a partnership
agreement that dictates the actual deal
because this would have been solved
right now it's a complete handshake and
so everybody just gets to freaking make
it up as they go
and no wonder you ended up in a
disagreement
but so what happened what's the downside
of selling it now don't you don't just
go and sell it and get out of it
it would be the capital gains i wouldn't
make the profit on it that i thought i
would and interest rates are twice as
high as what i paid before so i would be
getting a much smaller house for
probably the same payment
yeah but you're this is it's not going
to change substantially by next
spring i could sell one of my investment
properties
the reason you just gave me for selling
this house doesn't change by next spring
interest rates are not going to be back
down to 3 by spring
and you're still going to have capital
gains
in the spring
on a primary home if it's two years oh
you haven't held it yet two years no
what's the two year mark two years march
of 2023 oh
that's the deal okay
that was the deal yeah okay
and what is his basis that he thinks
he's due this money right now
when it wasn't the agreement
he
wants me to quit claim the title over to
him and
him and me instead of just me
and because i won't do that then he's
calling
for all of his money back yeah but that
wasn't the deal
so he just thinks he can just change
deals whenever he wants
yeah
even if they're handshake deals right
yeah so he just makes up crap as he
wakes up in the morning goes i want a
different thing right
yeah yeah i'm curious do you think he's
hurting financially right now
i think he is he also has um he's going
to get a kidney transplant so i think
he's getting worried that
um i if anything happens to him in the
surgery that i would keep his money
um
okay
so cause you're absolutely that woman i
mean you just keep people's money all
the time this guy's a clown show man um
we have a son together and it would just
go to our son
hypothetically
i wonder if he's bluffing dave because
he's hurting financially he doesn't want
to accrue a bunch of legal fees so you
owe 675 it's worth what
1.2 million
okay um
so here's what i would here's what i
would tell him number one i would go
hire an attorney
and i would spend two thousand dollars
on that and give somebody two or five
thousand dollar retainer and say um okay
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna punch this guy's lights out all
right let's start with that and then
once when he wakes up from getting
punched in the face
metaphorically speaking um
then what we'll do is we'll say listen
if you really want out of this our deal
was real clear house was in my name that
was our deal it was going to sell in
march that was our deal you're freaking
out over your kidneys and if you want to
change the deal and you want to be
bought out early you're going to you're
going to have to do it at a discount
i'll give you 100 grand
okay
and i'll go borrow that on a home equity
loan
and then you sit on this puppy and move
it in the spring
so let me just throw in i'm going to
play dr john doloni for a second
this guy's been pulling your strings a
lot of years and he kind of enjoys it
and you've been letting him get away
with it and i'm listening to you
acquiesce to him on this call
yeah that's kind of what i do yeah
instead i think this is the time it
changes
this is the time you decide uh uh i'm
done with you by the way you're the
ex-husband for a reason because you're
this twerp
that's why we call you x
okay and so you don't get to call stuff
in my life you don't get to make up
stuff you don't get to jerk me around
anymore and oh by the way everybody out
there listening don't go in business
deals with your ex
just there's a reason they're an ex
so
you know this is a simple simple
equation so yeah yeah lisa this is
you're just really a sweet person
and i'm more pissed off at him right now
than you are
and that's weird
so you need to you need to
metaphorically double up your fist and
say throw your shoulders back and say uh
uh i'm done
the days of you pushing this little lisa
around is done
so here's what you get bubba nothing but
an attorney bill or if you're freaking
out you want to be a bozo you want to
continue to be a clown show i'll buy you
out for 100. if you don't want to do
that let's fight
because by the time you get to court
it's going to be spring
dumb but
you know you're not even going to get
your money on
any sooner by going to court unless he
intimidates your butt
with this that's the only way he's
getting money this does not go to trial
before spring
not a chance the courts are all backed
up with covid right now it does not go
to trial that fast so you need a good
attorney and someone that'll give you
enough information that gives you some
courage and um
and you need to put this guy in a
completely different box than you've
ever put him in before in how you handle
him going forward on issues related to
your son
because other than that you shouldn't
have any further relationship with this
guy at all
yeah call his bluff it says simple call
his bluff i think he's bluffing uh as
you just admitted he's manipulated you
before he you have the leverage he
doesn't he will spend he's not going to
spend any money to fight this in court
because he doesn't have a case and he
knows it
i don't think he's got that either
that's my point i i'd call his bluff um
i'd hate to see you take out a home
equity line of credit when you could at
least draw a line in the sand and say no
if you can buy them out and at you know
yeah 65 cents on the dollar i'll buy him
out yeah i get it you went out early but
you know it says there's a cost of that
but if you want to stay in the deal this
is what it is but here's the thing he's
not going to get any money unless you
give it to him
in any scenario before spring
yeah unless you cave absolutely that's
the line yeah because he can't get it
through courts that fast